il y aurait plus de 60 millions
d'animaux de compagnie en france mais
c'est un marché de plusieurs milliards
d'euros et donc forcément cela attire
les trafiquants en tout genre grand
reportage s'est intéressé à ce trafic
d'animaux parmi les plus importants au
monde
le commerce illicite d'animaux se
classerait au troisième rang des trafics
les plus lucratifs
après la vente de drogue et d'armes
[Musique]
des espèces protégées vendus sous le
manteau
[Musique]
les boutiques de 60 euros
pour mettre nice et
une recrudescence des vols alors c'est
le troisième plus gros trafic illégal
mondiale c'est entre 15 et 60 milliards
d'euros par an soit ils ont fait le
calcul
plus de 5000 euros de braconnage par
seconde
un truc de dingue qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce que l'on lutte
suffisamment efficacement est ce que les
peines sont à hauteur du préjudice ou
est-ce qu'elles ne sont pas assez haute
on va commencer par vous caroline parce
qu'on en pense c'est que le double
discours est très pénible c'est à dire
que tu as dit longtemps depuis des mois
et des années maintenant il faut des
animaux de compagnie je parle surtout
des chiens et des chats
moi aussi beaucoup dans le reportage
voilà on nous on nous serine le truc
marche pas ça existe oui c'est un peu ce
rennais pensaient que j'allais bien dire
mais la prod évoqua rollins rendez vous
en direct pendant l'émission
donc on nous serine quoi exactement là
qu'il faut des animaux de compagnie non
on a bon coeur sans prendre un animal de
compagnie et une fois qu'on est malade
mais je parle vraiment essentiellement
des chiens et des chats qu'on voit pas
dans l'extrême et qu'on voit beaucoup
dans le reportage
une fois qu'on en a un il faudrait qu'on
se méfie pour savoir d'où il vient
quelle est sa base c'est la moindre des
choses quand même caroline récup amusant
banon c'est moi par exemple c'est pas la
première chose à laquelle je vais penser
si j'ai envie d'un petit chien un petit
show très mignon et de races et ça reste
encore mon problème est que j'ai pas
envie de l'adopter j'ai envie de
d'acheter un chien de race
il faudrait que en plus de ça je me
demande quelle est sa provenance est ce
que il vient à priori ce ne serait ce
que pour ne serait ce que pour le
bien-être de l'animal d'abord et puis 2e
puis j'imagine que si vous prenez un
bain ainsi vous avez envie d'un chiot
c'est parce que peut-être vos enfants
réclament un bébé chien et en
l'occurrence c'est aussi leur éviter de
la grande tristesse parce que
malheureusement souvent ces animaux là
ne vivent pas bien longtemps s'ils ont
été maltraités sevré trop tôt leurs
accélérations ne culpabilise ont créé
une psychose la houlala rosaria pas
forcément besoin de la créer et je suis
du coup je suis un petit peu énervé
d'accord bon très bien que
ludivine pardon comme d'habitude ma
copine veut toujours prendre part au
grand banditisme ou crime organisé
puisque c'est la seule à c'est ce que ça
finances carolina elle est sérieuse
quand elle dit on me demande voir
l'origine va t'acheter un manteau chéri
ne peut pas griffé qu'il est faussement
de riffs et dans la stricte et ben
pareil on la police va venir te dire
madame vous n'avez pas droit parce que
un moment donné tu peux pas
révolutionner mais je savais faire et
l'eau se faisait passer pour tata
journée à faire ça je place toute ma
journée à personne mais j'essaie en tout
cas de marchés qu'en même temps dans
dans les clous caroline exagère sûr ça
représente des milliards d'euros comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est
juste innommable destructeur pour la
biodiversité parce que la plupart du
temps ce sont des espèces protégées qui
sont acheminés de façon mais totalement
b notamment pour léna car ce qu'on
appelle les nac les nouveaux animaux de
compagnie exact où l'ont effectivement
lors plus les animaux sont rares pluies
sont chers et plus en ville chez eux des
carapaces de tortues ils ont d d d d
idées totalement absurde et des reptiles
et où des volatiles et je rappelle quand
même que les blés les personnes qui
utilisent son préposé risque entre sept
ans de prison et 150 mille euros damende
cessionnaire hypocrite parce que ce sont
les mêmes qui défendent les animaux qui
disent moi j'aime les animaux je vais en
avoir chez moi et de ont transformé les
animaux en signe extérieur de richesse
ça veut dire tu dois avoir une panthère
quand tu habites dans certains pays pour
être très luxe ici si je prends les
termes de kharouba ouais il me faut un
chien pure race j'irai pas l'acheter à
la sp alors que c'est à la spa qu'il
faudrait aller sauver un chien si tu
aimes vraiment les animaux
d'abord d'ailleurs on les salue à
l'aspect y font un travail absolument
formidable on a reçu son président ici
il ya des opérations portes ouvertes un
peu partout alors n'hésitez pas et
évidemment on encourage
justement vous vous dites vous dit pas
il faudrait fermer les animaleries etc
vous vous dites moi si j'ai envie
d'avoir un chien je peux aller chercher
au moins précisément est enfin là je
parle au nom des gens qui préfèrent
encore aujourd'hui avoir un bébé chien
d'une race précisé qu'ils préfèrent
aller l'acheter jeunes 16 ou et pardon
il y en a beaucoup et bien lieu demain
n'est pas du tout s'il aimerait bien que
dans les gens là on les met pas dans une
sorte de psychose inutile et qu'il
culpabilise pas de en plus se dire déjà
jette un chien donc je vais être mal vu
en plus il faut que je sache d'où il
vient et serra pour être sûr de mon coup
je trouve que c'est des reportages qui
se porte qui font flipper et qui servent
pas on n'a pas grand chose mais ça
s'applique pas évidemment à des nac à
des tigres à des panthères je parle
vraiment d
xavier madrid pour le consommateur de
nous faire encore porter le chapeau mais
les animaleries qui ont fermé elles ont
été justement les ce sont les gens qui
en quiconque y sont responsables de ça
alors que les allemands veulent rien
acheter des animaux
justement qui venaient des pays
étrangers sans origine etc
puis elle écrivait chien ou chat à leur
chat d'origine persan alors les gens
pensaient qu'ils avaient acheté un
persan mais en réalité il avait acheté
un chat pas cher et il le faisait passer
pour un chat persan parce qu'il avait la
gueule d'un père cent donc ça ça fabrice
lendemain christ sur les trafics est ce
que vous estimez que lorsqu'il ya
démantèlement par exemple de trafic et
cetera est ce que il épelle vous
conviennent escales sont suffisantes
thibault il ya un vrai problème là
dessus on n'arrivera pas à concilier
jean-michel beyoncé n'est ni caroline
c'est d'ailleurs parce que une marche
dans les clous pas dans les clous mais
justement là où est le problème c'est au
niveau des réseaux est un démantèlement
ya pas si longtemps et quelques mois oui
et le chef le chef du réseau
il n'a pris que six mois avec sursis de
prison avec 5000 euros damende on en est
là au niveau de l'union européenne de la
france donc c'est une déception énorme
et tant qu'il y aura ce à qui aura pas
de peine et d'amandes plus fort à ce
qu'on estime que j'imagine que est-ce
que c'est pas si grave que voilà ça pas
de la drogue c'est pas donc on est on a
le sentiment qu'il s'est un peu à minima
quoi un minime à chaque fois vous dites
nous ce que vous en pensez
sur ces trafics en tout genre et qui est
un marché de plusieurs milliards est ce
que vous dites comme caroline que ce
sont les entre guillemets propres et
futurs propriétaires qui sont
culpabilisés où vous dites non c'est à
nous aussi de nous responsabiliser de
faire attention à ce que l'on fait est
que nos actes ont des conséquences
hashtag sécu dlt en tout cas attention
quand vous volez des animaux parce
qu'ils se vengent
la perte et les serveurs